es el último discurso que dan ambos
candidatos presidenciales antes de la
segunda vuelta
[Aplausos]
quema el cristal Blue explicó a sus
seguidores sus planes sobre un programa
de seguro familiar en el que prometió
que ninguna mujer necesitará confiar
Nunca más en el poder de un hombre él se
ha presentado como la opción inclusiva y
ha prometido fortalecer la democracia en
Turquía incluido el regreso de un
sistema parlamentario de gobierno y la
independencia de un poder judicial en su
aparición en ankara también denunció
obstrucciones en su campaña no puedo
enviar mensajes de texto a los
periodistas para anunciar nuestro
programa de campaña las empresas de
telecomunicaciones me impiden tener
comunicación directa con los periodistas
estoy bajo una sombra Total le pregunta
ardogan quieres que entre a las
elecciones ni siquiera podemos celebrar
elecciones en Turquía este hombre es un
cobarde
desde Estambul receta gildogan convocó a
sus seguidores y los motivó para que no
se pierdan ni uno de los votos que
consiguió en la primera vuelta cuando
estuvo A pocas décimas del 50 por ciento
necesario para ganar vamos a ir mañana a
las urnas
emitiremos nuestros votos desde las
primeras horas de la mañana
no perderemos a nadie que votó en la
primera vuelta verdad están de acuerdo
en la primera vuelta la participación
fue del 87% y muchos turcos consideran
indispensables salir a votar
definitivamente una elección muy
importante para nuestro país pero si
preguntas Quién va a ganar Nadie puede
decirlo porque está codo a codo
es indispensable que todos salgan a
votar para la continuidad de nuestro
estado y su prosperidad
sea cual sea el ganador deberá afrontar
grandes desafíos del país como la
delicada situación con los refugiados
sirios en territorio Turco y la crisis
económica que golpea el bolsillo de los
ciudadanos